Being the last one on the last day of the
presentation in the Side Track.
I'm impressed that there are still people
here that are not sleeping.
It's professionally what we call this slot
the twilight zone.
And I know that you guys are tired after two
days of conferencing and learning and JavaScripting.
So, I hope that this talk is going to be a
little fun for you.
That said, you know, like I've added a few
jokes here and there.
But my wife tells me that my dad jokes are
absolutely terrible.
So, we'll see how that works out for you guys.
Nobody laughs.
That's a good start.
Hi.
My name is Pier.
You might remember me from such amazing projects
such as: The Java servlet API.
The Java API for XML.
Java 2 SE 1.5.
And a lot more Java goodness.
I'm sure right now you're actually wondering
whether I am at the right conference here.
Well, I am.
You see, like a few years back when I was
living in Tokyo, I met this fine gentleman.
His name is Jed Schmidt.
We were working together.
And he's one of the creators of, for example,
Brooklyn Jazz.
Quite a famous name over there.
And thanks to the beatings of these fine gentlemen
I kind of like praise the Lord.
I saw the light.
I abandoned the dark side.
And converted to this wonderful world of Node.js.
Let me tell you, life since then has been
all ponies and rainbows.
But I want to point out one thing.
I know that I'm gonna anger some of you here.
I am not a, you know, like I'm definitely
not into Star Wars.
I'm more of a Trekkie myself.
But enough about me.
Let's get into the nitty gritty details of
this talk.
So, today we're talking about the almighty
toilet paper roll.
And now I'm sure that you're really wondering,
am I at the right conference?
How many of you are familiar with this wonderful
object?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, you know, if not this one, we can
get the black one.
It's so Berlin.
You know?
Amazing.
For your health, I really hope that you had
a good use of this today.
You know?
But what about JavaScript?
And toilet paper?
Well, let's take a step back.
You see, a couple of years back I took a job
at a company called Korber, a big giant in
industrial manufacturing in Germany.
They are one of the largest manufacturers
of industrial machines.
Including, amongst a thousand other things,
tobacco machines, palletizing equipment, we
actually do produce machines that produce
toilet paper and kitchen rolls.
I am embedded with their digital lab.
Korber Digital.
And we develop digital applications for our
customers, right?
More specifically, I am in a team that develops
this wonderful app.
What we're building is called K Edge.
K Edge is an app that has been designed to
offer shift support in for the operators of
toilet paper machines, right?
On KEdge, as you can see there, like, you
know, operators of operators of these machines
can actually see their production stats like
how many logs they have produced, the average
speed at which the machine is running, downtimes
and whatnot.
They can see the telemetry from the machine
itself.
You can see actually the graph over there.
We take that graph, we analyze the speed,
we create yellow segments or red segments.
Yellow segments are reduced productivity so
that when we are below that green line you
see over there.
And the red segments is when the machine is
actually stopped.
So, what happens, the operator at that point
has the ability to create a digital report
of their shift, right?
So, KEdge is deployed as on a tablet that
goes alongside the traditional HMI.
The HMI is that big computer you see there
that controls actually the machine itself.
And the operators use the tablet to create
a digital journal of their shift.
And, you know, replace their old paperbased
trail of stuff.
Right?
So, let's look a little bit about how KEdge
is built.
So, this is a quick outline of our architecture.
The frontend is a React app.
So, lots of JavaScript.
It's deployed statically on Amazon S3, served
through Cloud front and a login will be handled
by incognito really soon.
And backup communication goes through Redux
to a bunch of JavaScript microservices which
have been deployed as Amazon Lambda functions
and therefore accessible via the AWS gateway.
Interesting, isn't it?
No.
It's 2019.
Nobody cares about another god damned React
app.
You know, if we were to talk about this, you
might just as well go out to the beach and
catch some sun while you can.
You know, enjoy the heat and so on and so
forth.
And so, what's actually interesting about
what we do?
Well, to figure that out, we have to see how
toilet paper is actually produced, right?
So, thanks to the National Geographic, this
is how a modern toilet paper factory looks
on the inside.
This has been shot at one of the biggest producers
of toilet paper here in the European market.
And you can actually hear how loud this place
is.
Right? [it's loud]
Giant factories, just to make toilet paper.
But easier on the ears, let's look a little
bit at how our production line is actually
configured.
This is a pretty machine, one of ours.
Wonderful piece of equipment that runs at
around 50 kilometers an hour.
And how is toilet paper produced?
We start from the top left with some giant
jumble rolls, we call them.
Those are three tons of paper.
Oneply paper.
To put that into perspective, one of those
rolls is enough for at least three of you
to make toilet paper for the rest of your
life kind of thing.
So, pretty big.
We unwind those ones, right?
And we unwind them one, two, or three or four
of them depending if we want one, two, three
or fourply toilet paper.
After the winders over here, we have what
is called the embosser.
It basically takes the splice of toilet paper,
pushes them together and embosses this nice
pattern over here.
And in the process, it injects air into the
paper.
So, it makes it thicker, it makes it fluffier,
softer, gentler on your rear end, maybe.
And after the paper is embossed, basically
what happens is that the cardboard core here
gets produced by the machine that you see
in the middle over there.
The cardboard core slides in and we actually
start rewinding the embossed paper around
the cardboard core in giant logs.
It's like this, but it's 3 meters wrong.
Those go into the thing that look like a cage,
it's an accumulator, buffering the unwinding
part at the top from the cutting and packaging
at the rear end of the line.
You see at the very top over there, we have
a log saw, which basically take this is log
and cuts it and makes these things.
And then quickly, the at the left no, sorry,
at the right of your screen we see the packager.
That basically, you know, takes four, eight,
12 toilet paper rolls, puts them together,
wraps them around.
Nice package at the supermarket.
And at the bottom, the palletizer.
And they are stacked up and put in a pact
and, boom, ready for shipping.
But now you will be asking, is all of this
controlled with JavaScript?
No.
Production a production line even the modern
production lines are controlled by something
called a PLC or programmable logic controller.
I like to call them legacy hardware from the
last century.
This is a last generation Siemens S7 1500,
top of the line.
Great PLC.
There is one little problem with these beasts
that they are still programmed using a thing
called lather logic.
This is an example of a program.
But, you know, like in the PLCs themselves,
we don't have variables.
In most of the PLCs we address variables are
their location in the memory.
We don't know exactly what's stored here and
there.
This is definitely not for the faint of heart.
Programming one of those things makes COBOL
look so 2019.
You know?
And if it's not bad enough, we actually don't
work on these beautiful brand new machines
most of the time.
We use them on the machines that have been
in the field for like 10, 15 years.
This is normally how we find a PLC.
This is Inga.
It's a machine that I had to connect in order
to extract data from in order for our application
to work correctly, right?
And it's a jungle of wire.
And how do we extract data from this medieval
piece of kit?
Well, we add more wires.
We add, you know, like more wires and an industrial
PC in there which we call the gateway.
And the gateway connected on one side to the
PLC with the beautiful' they are Internet
table.
And thanks to our friends at Twilio, we have
a dedicated connection that pumps the data
down to the cloud, right?
And this, the gateway, is where we run all
this JavaScript goodness that we wrote.
But before we get into the JavaScript part,
like I wanted to show you a little bit the
connectivity scenario.
So, on the left we have the little factory
which is our PLC while in the middle the chip
is our gateway, running node.
And bridges kind of like the time gap between,
you know, like the between the last century
and now.
And obviously we have the cloud.
So, the data flow here is interesting.
Because being stuck in the past, that PLC
does not know anything about encryption, security,
not even a password, right?
If I can read from a PLC, I can write to it,
I can reprogram it, I can do whatever I want
with it.
And the only thing that I need to do that
is an IP address which I can connect to.
Now, this is very insecure.
That has been used many times in the past.
Probably the most famous case is when all
the centrifuges in Iran for processing uranium
were disabled by malicious code by disabling
the PLC that spun up the centrifuges and boom,
it's gone.
But when we push the data through the include,
we want everything to be safe.
So, we started looking at the physical boundaries
of security.
And so, we install our gateway into the cabinet
where the PLC is.
We only have one cable.
Nothing gets in, nothing gets out.
Nobody contacts the PLC from outside of the
cabinet of the PLC itself, right?
And outside when we want to reach through
the cloud, you know, like we have a nice secure
modern Linuxbased like VPN on top of an LTE
link and yada, yada, yada, right?
So, we actually implement we actually define
a security perimeter around the PLC so that
we can protect it from attacks.
And we do this by installing the gateway with
a PLC itself, right?
The gateway itself also serves another bunch
of purposes.
We want to consolidate data.
Because as much as our friends at Twilio advertise
their 4G, in most cases factories are, you
know, they're not very well in terms of reception.
Most of the times we get 2G, 40 kilo bytes
a second.
That's not quite enough to actually have a
full stream of data coming out.
We actually do a lot of the data consolidation
on the gateway itself.
That's why we need the processing power of
JavaScript to do that.
And so, we send only, for example, the data
that changes in the PLC.
And we also do a lot of caching.
So, we do we cache everything that we read
on to the device itself because, well, it's
2G.
When and, you know, whatever connectivity
comes and goes and so on and so forth.
In case of connectivity failures, and some
hiccup occurs, we can quickly, or as quick
as we can, reingest all the data that we've
read while that link was down and then continue
at normal operation, right?
So, we started this thing with a wonderful
program by IBM Research that was called Node
Read.
It's a wonderful tool.
It has libraries that allows us to connect
to the PLC.
And you see here a very easy configuration,
every 10 seconds we have the speed, and we
have the first alarm.
Shift it down to the right.
Send it over to Amazon, right?
This is great.
Nice going.
Can do things very quickly.
It's all based in JavaScript, and it's amazing,
but gets really complicated when we start
reading like a bunch of variables.
This is actually a real configuration file
we had in production when we started reading
more valuables to the thing.
And it really gets a mess.
It becomes like a bunch of wires.
You never know who is changing what.
We cannot manage these files and so on and
so forth.
So, a year ago roughly it dawned on me, you
know what?
We have the technology.
We're going to rebuild it.
And we came up with a thing that is called
the PLC reader.
PLC reader is a wonderful little Node.js application
that we wrote in order to clean up the mess
that was Node Read.
JavaScript, why?
Because it was built in Node.
Continue with Node because we had the reliability
over there.
But we managed to bring some automation into
the world of point and click, right?
It does a very simple job.
It reads values from various sources, which
we call drivers.
And processes in various ways through a pipeline
of what we call processers.
Right?
On top of that, it's easily deployed as a
Debian package.
We bought a tool, Debianize.
It's not point and click, but it's YAML files.
Easy to manage, get, central, we can track
who changes what and convert with CircleCI
and Ansible to anywhere we want.
All right?
So, let's look at one of those configuration
files.
Very, very easily here, we have one driver.
A driver that, guess what, next to a PLC.
A Siemens S7PC, we have the IP address in
the port which we connect to, read and write.
Rack and slot our particular parameters for
the RFC106 protocol that we're using to talk
to these things.
And what's important is that every 2 seconds
we read these variable or better, we read
these memory addresses at DB 5102.
And at offset 12.
That's a word.
And that's basically a sign 16.
That's what we call speed.
That's where we find the speed that the machine
is running.
At offset 36, we see the code of the first
alarm and so on and so forth.
That's one of the drivers.
We have many drivers which we wrote.
And to monitor the performance of the gateway.
Here I just listed like load average
Every 10 seconds we read the load average,
CPU percentages, every 10 seconds, calculate
the percentage of the CPU used.
And we have latency to monitor the connection.
And this is how we start getting data into
the system, right?
Doing that is very easy, we have processers
organized one after the other.
Each process can subscribe to one, two, many,
all of the values that are published by the
drivers or are republished by the processers.
And here we have very simple example of three
processers that we are actually using.
The first one is a function.
The only line of JavaScript that probably
you will see in my talk.
Which takes this speed which in the machine
is published in decimeters per minute.
I don't know why.
But we divide by ten, meters per minute.
And the second one is string, we read alarms
as unsigned 16bit integers.
But they're not numbers, we make an average
on an alarm code.
We convert them into strings and consolidate.
Like I said before, if the alarm changes,
we publish it.
Otherwise, if the alarm is not changed, we
swallow that message, right?
But the most important probably processers
that we have are like the last two that we
use at the end of the pipeline.
The batcher and the MQTT.
The batcher is very simply something that
subscribes to all the messages, accumulates
them, and every 30 seconds pushes out that
thing that you see like over there.
Functions out a message.
Which is no more, no less than an array of
timestamp at which the data was read and the
vault of the data point.
Giant array.
We also compress it so it's nice and tiny
when we send over our 2G link.
And then the MQTT processer does what it's
supposed to be doing.
Sends it over to MQTT secure, blah, blah,
blah, blah.
Very nays, right?
This is how we use JavaScript.
Everything behind this Y ML fuel, ever processer,
every driver, the entire infrastructure to
drive this thing is written in JavaScript.
And we're using it like like it's been a labor
of love.
We are extremely proud that it's running in
production at real customer's sites.
It's feeding KEdge with live real data.
It has been working out great.
If you are a dad and, you know, maybe how
proud you are.
The other thing that I mentioned, there were
a couple of extra things.
Enough with the kit.
YAML.
We've wrote a bunch of YAML extensions which
we needed for these configuration files.
YAML is great, but it's also terrible.
It doesn't allow including, it doesn't allow
a bunch of things.
So, we wrote a little extension over there
to merge a raise over raise.
So, if we have in one file define a list of
drivers and in another file another list of
drivers, we can just merge them together.
It works great, obviously with the include
driver.
So, we include a part a snippet of YAML into
another file.
Making sure that all the variables are visible
by the included files and whatnot.
So, there is a little bit of logic over there.
And then the last one we use a lots for configs
ration is the join which takes a lot of joins
and concatenates them into a giant string.
It's great for variables, a certificate ID
that repeats 25 million times in our configuration
files.
Right?
The other thing that I talked about was Debianize,
it's a tool we wrote in order to take your
npm package and have it as a Deb.
Why?
We use Ubuntu on our gateways.
It was easy to get it out of the way.
You just slap it in your package.JSON, and
then run the npm, this is the configuration
of the PLC reader in itself.
It's very complex.
It has sensible defaults so it's a one line
of addition.
Makes a Debian package for you.
So, what's the state for us?
What's the state in terms of all the stuff
we have wrote so far?
We have PLC reader which is open source.
You can just check it out on npm.
We have Debianize which is out for everybody
to use.
YAML extensions, open source, get them, download
them even if you don't care about PLCs or
industrial machines.
They're there.
They work.
We also throw in because you're such a good
audience, we throw in a freebie, the IRONdb
persister.
That's the time series database we use for
telemetry data.
It was a fantastic database created by a friend
of mine, Theo.
But they had no JavaScript drivers for them,
so we wrote them and they're also available
for you guys to use if you use IRONdb.
And that's pretty much it for me because I
think that I have two minutes and I was wonder
for you guys have any questions?
Sure.
AUDIENCE: [ Away from microphone ]
PIER: Because that's right.
Because actually it is readable enough that
it can be handled by presale support.
Because in most for the inclusions.
That's why we wrote the YAML extensions.
There are parts that people don't touch.
But, for example, the list of addresses in
the memory, in the PLC, that comes from an
Excel file that the machine manufacturer actually
makes.
So, that one is handled by a different team.
When they change the PLC programming, they
can just change that part.
And then, you know, like all the rest flows
together.
So, that's why we chose to use YAML rather
than JavaScript for that.
Yeah.
Anything else?
There was a question over there at the bottom.
But, you know, like I guess, nobody picks
it up.
AUDIENCE: [ Away from microphone ]
PIER: Wow.
Such an amazing question, right?
I spent the first 15 years of my career building
Java systems.
I'm one of the cofounders of Jakarta and the
XML Apache projects and I have been doing
XML since 1997.
For me it's like PLC reader, it's a labor
of love.
The problem over there is that we have seen
that there is an aggressive actor in the Java
world that is actually starting to copyright
and push their copyright of the APIs out.
And we're talking about Oracle over there.
That didn't give us confidence that what we
were building for especially in this case
when these gateways are over a 2G link, we
didn't have the confidence that we could update
the Java virtual machine every six months
like Oracle wants us to do kind of thing.
And I know that Amazon came out with some
wonderful things on their side.
But I wonder how long those are going to last
in a court.
So, JavaScript, on the other hand, you know,
ECMA, pretty much every implementation out
there is open source.
And it gives us the stability that we need.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]